pata
pata comme papa a part ça
la patate à la pâte à tarte tatin de sa
femme papa tu as ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta
maman comme fonds vont nous cherchons
nous
[Musique]
quittons printemps
il échappe
c'est entendu pardonnez moi chers amis
les ponts qu'il faut pas bon et qu'un
assaut pointe noire écoutez c'est fou
comme ça je peux comme au temps de
chanter en face on ne saurait pas mal à
paris sont profonds oui à las vegas et
oui si je chante si fort au lieu
d'imiter le gazouillis des oiseaux c'est
parce que juillet françois couvrat
m'avoir
pas si on peut même plus chanter
maintenant à bastia c'est ensemble les
ponts qui font un bon
point
m
[Musique]
quoi
1000 milles et 1000 que vous un style
enfin cette chute
n'est rien du tout enfin ça ça criait
pouvoir
je les trouvais rien d'autre pour vous
faire taire j'ai réussi par mois
bon alors maintenant je peux chanter oui
ah non non non casimir j'ai j'ai une
carte postale à vous lire et elle est
adressée à nous tous
bon alors je je lis
amicale pensée à tous
signés ennemi chutait
c'est tout il nous interrompt pour pour
une carte aussi peu important au thorium
de sus du snob un facteur n'a pas à
prendre en considération le texte d'une
carte postale le courrier c'est toujours
important bon ça va alors maintenant
est-ce que je peux chanter
tu as envie de chanter
alors là j'ai une idée
si monsieur du snob le permet en tant
que président du comité des fêtes de
l'île aux enfants je propose de créer
une chorale
tellement génial je considère que c'est
moi qui ai trouvé la première
on commence avait écouté tout à l'heure
je vais aller chercher des partitions
c'est l'entité la police
[Musique]
là je me dépêche de préparer mes ballons
car tout à l'heure il n'en sera plus
question pour moi c'était encore pire il
faut que je mette de l'ordre dans tous
mes jouets et que j'ai ticket tous mes
bonbons avant la répétition nous voilà
casimir m'a aidé à porter les partitions
j'ai découvert une très jolie chanson
j'ai apporté également diapason bon
allez je vais poser les partitions sur
le membre très bien
j'espère que ça fait trop attendre
figurez vous que je me suis souvenu que
j'avais chez moi une véritable baguette
de chef d'orchestre ayant appartenu à
mon grand oncle sosthène des snobs et à
des plus illustres génie du siècle
dernier le renard bleu terre par faveur
spéciale l'avait autorisée à apporter le
nom de soeur de snobs qui vous dire à
quel point je vous en prie mais mettons
nous en place un aller vite qui va
diriger au fait c'est bien françois tu
que nous seuls faits jouit bon sur moi
je préfère chanter avec ma foi prend toi
c'est d'accord quant à moi avec mes
antécédents j'aurais jamais la patience
de diriger des débutants données massa
puisque tout le monde est d'accord
casimir
la
meilleure casimir ça va pas ça irait
beaucoup mieux si je pouvais m'éclaircir
à voir il parade pour cela les bonbons
au miel sont excellentes
voilà tu peux me donner toute la poignée
à ça ne fera pas de mal merci merci je
lui dis merci attention puisque tout le
monde est prêt avant de chanter chaque à
sa partie pour essayer une fois tous
ensemble d'accords une
2,12
nous sommes en tout
doucement doucement
me retire doucement doucement doucement
après la première phrase il y à un
silence on recommence une deux doucement
doucement
d'où sa
douce à main d'où 100 morts on visera
vous aimez écouter mes amis je crois que
nous allons en rester là avant la
deuxième réflexion je crois qu'il serait
utile de donner à casimir une petite
leçon de soul faire
ce n'est quand même pas de ma faute si
les autres me sens pas en mesure avec
moi
casimir le vieux nous allons faire un
peu de solfège d'accord qu'est ce que
c'est que ça une échelle avec des
barreaux verticaux des émirs applique
toi c'est une portée musicale un oui
c'est la composent des neuf d'accord
qu'est ce que c'est que ça une short
d'escargots c'est une clé de sol
face à lui un petit peu qu'est ce que
c'est que ça une clé à la clé de chez
moi
dont casimir c'est pas la clé de chez
doivent c'est la clé de sa banque les
martlets entre les fins d'accords qu'est
ce que c'est que ça des eaux du rhin que
j'aimais ce sont des rondes pas bon elle
va le 4 temps nous devrons encore
allemand fin qu'est ce que c'est que ça
alors tu vas me le dire eh bien ce sont
des blanches elles valent deux temps
d'accorder longue et ça facile là
maintenant ça c'est des blanches bronzer
ce sont des noirs
ce sont des noirs casimir elles valent
un temps bon d'accord et ça qu'est ce
que c'est pas ça c'est une noire un
poids plati il rappelle camille pas du
tout casimir ce sont des silences
d'accord tenir je te confie ses cartes
aux raies étudiées on a grand besoin
merci françois alors rondes noires
blanches graetzel silence à une ronde du
noir une blanche
silence à le cueillir le seul fait ça va
très bien au lieu de dormir pendant la
sieste j'ai appris ma partition parker
nous allons chanter chacun une phrase
très une deux d'où ce monde où cement
doucement s'en va le jour doucement
doucement
[Musique]
dans casimir tu t'es laissé surprendre
on recommençait in thé doucement
doucement
doucement fin val jour douce mort
enfin casimir que se passe-t-il
non ça comment que se passe-t-il
que se passe-t-il que ce parti pourquoi
est-ce que je suis toujours responsable
j'ai chanté exactement ce qui est écrit
l'un seulement eux ont appris les
paroles et moi j'ai appris les silences
[Musique]